we uh arrived in Melbourne on Thursday and got a
a quick tour of the facility you know things have
pretty much the same from our last visit last
fall when we got here building's been great uh
everything that they told us that we were going
to have when we arrived has been provided they've
really opened the doors to us and been very
welcoming similar to what we do for outdoor
games back in North America we have to kind
of create the structure that we're going to
build the ice rink on so we're doing that here
now everything you see for the game is what we
brought from North America so we sent over
three shipping containers there are a lot of
specialty items that our players are used to
having and they like to have so they're used
to our boards we have all the new features
with the soft cap the curved acrylic so we
want it to feel for the players just like it
would in their Rank and that's so that's why
we've sourced everything from back home and
brought it over here 1 2 3 it's special like
to be able to come over to Australia to do
a game like this I've I love what I do so to
be able to do it over here in Australia is is
fantastic you know it's a it's an opportunity
of a lifetime so I'm I'm pretty excited and
and we're looking forward to having the games
here